[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will showcase the
15 largest flying kaju that are seen in
live action movies this will include the
flying Titans from the monster verse and
Kaiju from the Pacific Rim universe as
well as those from Touhou movies and
entries from the Gamera Universe we will
try to rank them according to wingspan
and we will factor in their sizes for
the ones with our wings so let's get to
it
15 we have Gamera so the first one here
is a flying Kaiju but it has no wings
ironic right Gamera possesses an
extraordinary ability to fly by
utilizing powerful rocket-like jets that
emerge from his shell these just Propel
him through the air with great speed and
force enabling him to soar above the
Earth's surface and swiftly maneuver in
combat since he goes back into his shell
during flight we shall take his hands
that operate as gliding wings as the
size of the Wings
14 we have mega gyrus this is a
dragonfly Kaiju with a fusion of
Godzilla and mega neulon characteristics
she spots bumpy purple skin greenish
spikes and a reptilian head with a
tooth-filled mouth her body features
visible pectoral and abdominal muscles
distinguishing her from her insectoid
predecessors the mega nula she also has
a gigantic pair of wings
number 13 Des Ghidorah also known as the
death Ghidorah he is a demonic space
Kaiju that is a cousin of King Ghidorah
at least species wise is quadrupedal
unlike the bipedal guitarra it also has
three heads and two massive Wings which
enables it to fly and cause havoc on a
global scale its wings enable flight at
Mark 23 when in the atmosphere and
almost near light speed in space number
12 the muto male the hawk Mutual
possesses a somewhat insected body
structure with elongated limbs a
hunchback posture and large segmented
wings that enable it to fly it has sharp
blade-like volumes that it uses as
weapons and combat the hawk mutual's
head features a distinct cranial
structure and formidable mandibles
giving it a menacing and predatory look
also it can fly at supersonic speeds
number 11 Gigan this is a cyborg with a
blend of organic and mechanical features
gigan's design typically includes a
metallic exoskeleton razor sharp hooks
for hands and a single red visor like I
and also sometimes Buzz saw like weapons
embedded in the abdominal region and
also in the hands Gigan also doesn't
have wings even though it could fly so
its wingspan is calculated as the
maximum range of its arms side to side
number 10 batra portrayed as the
counterpart to Mothra batra is depicted
as an Avenger determined to punish
Humanity for its ecological
transgressions the creature's design
typically includes a bulky body an
armored exoskeleton and glowing red eyes
its wings are characterized by a
distinct shape resembling jacket blades
or serrated edges emphasizing its
destructive potential
number 9 the hyper Gauss this is the
largest variant of the GAO species in
the Gamera franchise it retains the
characteristics of the GAO such as its
pterodactyl batlike appearance sharp
talents and the ability to fly however
it possesses enhanced physical
attributes and abilities that make it
more of a formidable opponent it often
employs hit and run tactics with its
fast flying ability
number eight Iris also from the Gamera
franchise this is a mutated parasitic
demonic form of a Gauss the adult iris
is characterized by a striking
appearance combining elements of various
creatures in it it possesses multiple
technical-like appendages sharp claws
and a distinct eye-like organ on his
chest the organ is capable of emitting
powerful beams energy beams and can
regenerate itself if damaged the wings
are sort of like energy based with the
tentacles forming the skeletal frame
number six Otachi from the Pacific Rim
Universe Itachi is one of the largest
and heaviest category for kaju to ever
make landfall she is larger than other
Kaiju types in terms of length although
not Mars Itachi appears to walk on all
fours instead of standing upright like
some other types of Kaiju she is also
the only kaju in that universe that can
take flight with its massive wings
number 6 destoroya this is a mutation of
crustaceans exposed to the oxygen
Destroyer weapons effects resulting in a
hyper-evolving destructive creature in
its final form destoroya Stands Tall and
menacing resembling a combination of a
demonic dragon and a crustacean its
appearance features sharp Jagged Wings a
massive horn head and an array of jagged
teeth
number 5 war bats seen in GVK these are
large grayish greenish reptilian
creatures with large red membranous
wings along the upper part of their
elongated Serpentine bodies they have a
snake-like torso and ventral scales
allowing them to navigate a treacherous
terrain of the hollow Earth with ease
gliding and flying around hunting for
prey as well as other Titans
number 4 Mothra the most of us Mothra
has a sleek and streamlined Body cover
in vibrant and iridescent colors often
featuring a combination of blue teal and
hints of gold or yellow her wings are
beautifully patterned resembling stained
glass windows with integrate designs the
delicate and translucent nature of a
Wings adds to her ethereal and radiant
presence
number three is space Godzilla so in its
crystalline form space Godzilla presents
a striking and otherworldly appearance
emphasizing its extraterrestrial origin
and immense power its entire body is
encased in a shimmering Jagged Crystal
that range in color from bribly Blues to
deep purples so in this form it could
fly but at the same time its size is
Multiplied many fold especially in
weight anyway without wings we have to
take in the factor of its crystalline
form as the size
number two Rodan titanus Rodan boasts a
massive and imposing size emphasizing
its status as a super species its body
is covered in thick dark colored scales
with shades of brown or charcoal lava
gray one of the most striking features
of the most of us Rodan is its enormous
wingspan its wings feature a fiery red
or orange Hue with Smoky patterns and
they could generate hurricane-like wins
and number one Monster Zero till day the
largest Titan most of us starting to be
seen on screen is Monster Zero a life
that is there will be another video on
the three Titans bigger than it stay
tuned for that anyway the wings of
Monster Zero are not just for show they
are instrumental in its ability to fly
with unparalleled Grace and Agility it
can soar through the skies effortlessly
utilizing its immense wingspan to
dominate the airspace and it is
theorized to be the reason why Ghidorah
can create storms and hurricanes
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel take care
fam